maybe this was a mistake
[Music]
the United States has always had a
love-hate relationship when it comes to
train travel the country was literally
built on the backs of the railroads and
the US used to have the biggest and the
most well-funded rail network in the
world
but if you ask anybody that's taken the
Amtrak they'll tell you that that's not
exactly the case anymore
the U.S has fallen woefully behind the
rest of the world when it comes to train
travel so what the heck happened how did
the United States get so far behind and
does it have any chance of catching up
to find out the answer to that I'm going
to take the Amtrak from here in Los
Angeles all the way to New York City and
I'm going to have plenty of time to
think about it since it's a
70-hour Journey
I guess I better get started
[Music]
the entire length of my journey from Los
Angeles to New York is about four days
long and for the first leg of my journey
there weren't any sleeper cars available
so this is what my living space looks
like for the next two days which as
somebody that's years old should be
really good for my back the journey I'm
taking is pretty different than it would
have been about a hundred years ago to
see the differences let's take a look at
this U.S map the year is 1916 and
there's about 254 000 miles of railroads
the highest number there's ever been in
this country
the Pennsylvania Railroad or the Penzey
as it was referred to I feel like that
nickname could have probably used a
little more work nevertheless it was the
largest corporation in the world at the
time it's difficult to illustrate how
influential these companies were and how
much railroads were interwoven into the
fabric of American Life
they were responsible for the temples of
their time like Penn and Grand Central
stations also you would not believe how
amazing train travel could be back then
sure they had basic boring train cars
like the one I'm riding but the upscale
trains featured chandeliers barber shops
pianos and food service that would make
the Four Seasons look like Boston Market
one menu featured oysters consummate and
celery fed duck the bad news is my train
didn't have ducks that were fed anything
I ate the Thai Red Curry Street noodles
which although I'm pretty sure they were
just a microwave frozen package were
actually pretty good and although the
accommodations were a far cry from
crystal chandeliers they were
comfortable enough
[Music]
good evening ladies and gentlemen this
is the conductor speaking it has now
been five hours and 15 minutes which is
the time it takes to fly from LAX to
Newark Airport and we are still in
California
it's only nine o'clock but it already
got dark outside so there's nothing to
look out through the window and there's
no Wi-fi apparently so I guess I'm just
gonna go to sleep they leave the
overhead lights on all night but luckily
I brought my trusty eye mask
I also brought some earplugs which
should come in handy because I'm sitting
right in front of some iPad kids who are
watching movies at full volume with no
headphones
so that's fun
all right I'll see you in the morning
[Music]
did I sleep well last night
hmm
I'm going to say no I'll spare you the
details but imagine getting literally
kicked in the head by the woman in the
seat next to you I wound up retreating
to the observation car to sleep which
was less than ideal
like an astronaut in space I'm trying to
move around as much as I can so that my
muscles don't deteriorate during my
journey so let's talk about how American
trains went from gilded pleasure palaces
to this
part of the reason why railroads became
so wildly successful in the first place
is because they were run by what were
affectionately termed robber barons men
like Cornelius Vanderbilt Jay Gould
James Fisk and JP Morgan these guys were
ruthless anti-labor and really corrupt
which was great when it came to building
an expansive Kingdom of Highly
profitable rail companies but bad when
it came to
just about everything else as a result
the train companies became pretty
universally hated by the general public
as seen in what passed for scaling
satire at the time now
jockeying yo let him rip Commodore don't
stop to water or you'll be beat the
federal government saw the kind of crap
these guys were pulling in was like whoa
whoa whoa you can't do that so they
instituted a bunch of regulations which
among other things set fixed rates for
the railroad companies and also
prevented them from raising their fares
or changing their service without the
government's permission this didn't seem
like that big of a deal at the time
because as historian Robert self Henry
said the problem to some Minds at least
was how to keep railroads from making
too much money after all railroads were
still by far the most efficient and the
best way for most people to travel this
all obviously changed when affordable
Automobiles and later air travel came
into the picture so much so that by 1956
only four percent of Passenger travel
was on trains when you take into account
that 40 years earlier that number was 98
you can see how much the US's priorities
had shifted when it came to travel the
train companies were far from a monopoly
anymore but they were still being
regulated as if they were which was
killing them
okay so right now we are being held on
the tracks to let a freight train pass
and this is actually the perfect time to
talk about something private commercial
passenger trains have never been very
profitable
the lifeblood of the industry has always
been these freight trains but rail
companies were always forced to provide
passenger Service as a benefit to the
public so when the rail companies begin
to suffer and then eventually fold the
government had the idea to take the
responsibility for passenger service off
the plates of the rail companies who
could then focus on the profitable
Freight side of the business they took
all the passenger service and combined
it into one company which is how in 1971
we got Amtrak which stands for the
American train track again what is up
with these nicknames Amtrak makes it
easy come easy go to more than 450
cities in the USA but here is the thing
Amtrak was designed to fail from the
beginning that may sound ridiculous but
let me explain first of all the
government created Amtrak as a
for-profit corporation despite the fact
that virtually no passenger service
anywhere has been profitable after all
the government broke off all the
passenger trains from the rail companies
because they weren't making money when
the government formed Amtrak they tasked
it with employing Innovative operating
and marketing concepts to develop the
potential of modern rail service and how
much did Congress give them to do that
in their first year of operation
just 40 million dollars
their budget has gone up a lot since
then their budget for the year 2022 was
2.3 billion dollars which sounds like a
lot doesn't it but when you take into
account that the Federal Highway budget
for the same year was 64.3 billion
dollars you begin to see the inequity
to put it even more into perspective the
sum total of all the subsidies that the
U.S has allocated to Amtrak in its
entire history is less than one year's
funding for the interstate highway
system this right here shows where
America's priorities lie when it comes
to travel and why Amtrak has failed to
majorly expand or innovate
[Music]
okay so we just got to Chicago I got off
the Amtrak about 45 hours after I left
Los Angeles and needless to say
I do not smell very good I have about a
seven hour layover here in Chicago and
right now I'm in Union Station which is
actually kind of amazing
[Music]
as you see I got a chance to put on some
clean clothes which feels amazing and
now I'm just here in Millennium Park
rolling around with my suitcase like a
dang tourist and I'm just trying to
enjoy uh not being on a train as much as
possible before I get on the second leg
the second and final leg of my journey
[Music]
I've achieved the Holy Grail of my own
private room I want to show you my
favorite feature of the entire room
you're gonna like this
hidden sink this train is a little bit
more
Dynamic shall we say than the last one
but I'm hoping that all the movements
will just help rock me to sleep
foreign
[Music]
Ohio about 2600 miles through my journey
and 50 something hours
there are a lot of reasons why people
still want to take the train a big one
is the environment according to a study
by the University of Pennsylvania a
long-distance train trip produces 37
percent less emissions than taking a
flight trains are also much safer than
cars you're 17 times more likely to die
while driving than taking a train flying
and driving can be faster and sometimes
even cheaper than taking the Amtrak but
they're both often miserable experiences
going through TSA dealing with flight
delays or being stuck in traffic and not
being able to do anything because you
need to be driving the car while I've
been on Amtrak I've been able to just
stare out the window and see the country
go by or read a book or take a nap or
whatever I've been able to wander around
the train whenever I want and stretch my
legs and I've had the enjoyment of
having my own private little room and
this is with Amtrak being perpetually
and profoundly underfunded imagine what
it would be like if this were evened out
foreign
[Music]
so I made it all total it took me about
72 hours and 17 minutes which granted it
would have taken me between five and six
hours to fly that distance
um how I don't actually know the
distance off the top of my head but I'm
going to add it in post right here but
here's the thing
I had a good time it was actually really
fun aside from a couple of hiccups at
the very beginning it was a really
Pleasant memorable experience I got to
see parts of the country that I had
never seen before
and overall dare I say it was a pleasant
experience
right now Amtrak covers roughly 21 000
miles of Passenger rail in the U.S but
when you look at the map you can see its
sparse coverage routes that don't
connect and sorry Wyoming in South
Dakota you don't get any Trends if the
United States took Amtrak off life
support it would revolutionize the way
people travel around the U.S when he was
retiring former Amtrak president Graham
clayder said when I came to Amtrak I was
convinced I could save it but finally
came to the conclusion that only the
American public can save it when they
say they want it
now if you'll excuse me I'm gonna go
take a much needed shower and go to
sleep in a real bed
I gotta rest up for my flight back to
California tomorrow
for me one of the best parts of riding
the Amtrak is just
throwing on some Phoebe Bridgers and
wistfully staring out the window for
hours on end
foreign